let's talk about the gay mafia because
that's been the big story this week
because Bill Maher on overtime which is
the online only show
that they do on real time after the show
but he implied that they're actually
is a gay mafia let's take a look what do
you think I'm the Mozilla CEO having to
step down over his donation to pro
proposition 8 per be a
the Mozilla a which I'm wearing right
now
by the way a I didn't know what was the
law was not on my computer but
the its its Firefox rated the your
browser open and feed on this guy
apparently
does not want gay people to get married
and he had to step down
what do you think about the question is
because he gave a thousand dollars eight
years ago
units come back to haunt when he gave it
when President Obama
still with the anti-marriage so I don't
think it's very fair good point
also I think there is a gay mafia
my I think if you cross them
you do get why I'm sure okay I think
there were some
I had the sexual connotation to the way
he said whacked
was in there something there there's
back rows I and yellow and red
awfully rather something at the end so
it's a little bizarre
okay so they talk a little bit about the
Mozilla CEO is we just did in the
previous segment
I but keep the way bill says that he's
happy
joking but the way he sorta leaning in
his chair is also like
yeah I mean this thing I'm a in the
hollywood
I'm pretty entrenched and I know this
thing exists so you
to professional gay people does the gay
mafia exist anyway
no comment yeah
a have a champagne make it better I'm
getting there
you know they don't think that you don't
think there's an organized group a game
people that are meeting somewhere their
power for hauling in another organize I
think that occur but gave I think their
gay friend circles as there aren't any
professional
year setting and they do favors for each
other I don't believe that anyone is
pulling strings their mobile web yeah
right so with the right-wing people cuz
we got a list the things that people
claim that the gay mafia guys
they say that that you know they started
the fire storm a duck dynasty think that
was the gay mafia
but then the game I feel of that when I
guess is that anything still on Alec
Baldwin everybody's
paper 8 monger he likes get MSNBC that
must be the gay mafia
and that the CEO obviously a month or so
you guys really don't you just don't
believe
well I think what there is probably a
group of very wealthy game and that get
together and decide like wicket but
candidates they're gonna Bonn where
they're gonna put their money
the things they're gonna try to
influence with their dollars I don't
think that they're like
thinking that they're gonna make some
fire storm about duck dynasty I don't
know the media
yeah and I think the I'm with the
Firefox like it's its its public opinion
that that this guy was like gay mafia
now is public opinion that's why he step
down
I so I that I agree with that what
they're calling gay mafia really is just
glared hrc meaning
the rest that up which wedding like
those organizations are not every group
in this country has their advocacy
groups that are trying to to do things
would be the worst thing in the world if
we actually had a gay mafia
if he really became out yes there is a
group of gay people
trying to pull some strings for the gay
people become more equal
and you see better image is a gay people
immediately clear we got beat up
it's very like that the answer is no but
I think the gay mafia are all the 14
year old white girls
ont where bad backup there
people like you yeah into anal come to
YouTube and neighboring
over everything is everything going on
the horse a shirtless video with all the
14-year-old girls that click like the
year old man yeah
yeah I did back in the real game your
YouTube video at playlist live
and I had to kiss straight guys in it
and I was like no one is gonna kiss me
but no sorry guys can do this I have
like 60 14 overalls running with me up
to these guys like
are that is the battery mafia yeah
he kissed me yeah doing okay okay oh my
what I one that's good to hear every not
there
alright well there you have it I brought
onto professional gay youtubers I know a
little something about this write-up
and we don't know if there is a game at
which maybe means we're on
were on the outs probably are guided by
different guys and this is really a
round hole aa really
way if any work we're going to area